hot off the heels of scale bounds new
release date Microsoft has delayed
another game recore the upcoming
adventure game from Microsoft and mega
man creator Keiji Inafune a will not
launch this spring as originally planned
a Microsoft representative tells
engadget that the xbox one and pc game
is now slated to arrive during the
latter half 2016 however an exact
release date was not revealed require
was originally announced as an Xbox one
exclusive during Microsoft's e3 2015
briefing last summer at the time
Microsoft assigned a spring 2016 release
window just this week though microsoft
confirmed that recoil will also launch
on pc through windows 10 whether or not
it will also come to steam remains to be
seen when asked about steam availability
the Microsoft representative said we'll
have more to share soon on recourse so
please stay tuned Joseph statin the
co-creator of the halo and destiny
universes has been confirmed as the
project's lead writer and although
gameplay footage of recore has yet to be
demonstrated the e3 reveal trailer
suggests the game follows a young woman
who travels with a glowing blue orb that
can possess a range of robotic
companions for more enric or including
any possible upcoming release dates stay
tuned to gamespot com
you